what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation thank you so much for
clicking on this video what are we gonna
watch today Michael tesler MJ tesler the
michaelorian the Michael Oher the
midichlorians episode 5 of what season
John season three including everyone in
this intro because I am a generous Lord
anyway guys you know what to do leave a
like that's the proper way to go about
business I gotta grab grogu before we
film this episode reaction also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell at some point and it's midnight
right now we gotta shoot bad batch I
guess I got into that as well there's a
superior Star Wars series to keep a
lookout for that because you know come
hopefully within the next 24 to 48 hours
also um wanted to give a mention it was
supposed to arrive today but we had just
finished the design over the weekend at
shopzeroedition.com that's for all of
our real rejects merch is located we
have launched a new shirt that you can
now purchase and I'm telling you it's
one of greggy's favorites or should I
say daddy's favorite look at it we got
here look at that Joel daddy Pedro
holding up baby grogu and I love the
text says Child Protection Services I
think it's hilarious you get it guys
because Joe protects you guys get it I
don't know explain it you're smart but
yeah one of the best ways to support the
channel is by getting these awesome
designs we got plenty of stuff over
there and full interaction watch songs
of our patreon page let's get this show
on the road
[Music]
I'm here for my hot springs
where's the real spur we're going to be
moving a lot of cargo in and out of here
grief cargo hold on a second
got a bad feeling about this
Pirates
we did Jack you get the citizens to
safety I'll handle this Engineers thank
you to be continued Engineers I do not
know your names
oh
that's an opposing hologram all I see
before me is a Pampered nobleman dressed
for the pump of his wedding Feast
alliteration gunning down my Helmsman In
Cold Blood when he let down his guard on
your planet he shot first
nice reference
hail me again unless it's to surrender
oh no oh boy what you were supposed to
be Navarro's Savior and now he will be
its Reckoning
oh Lordy do are they about to destroy
Navarro yep
yeah
wow that is an aerial bombardment
those extras are having the time of
their life right now I will lead you to
the launch site I won't abandon my city
we have to get the people to safety he's
like Boba Fett
for motivation
getting some uh final season of Game of
Thrones Vibes right now
sure
[Music]
wow that's imposing
oh pirate up
accordion in there too
yes
Dope music this is epic I want to go to
a Star Wars Rave now
blow the situation is dire
I'm afraid that our planet will fall
shark will turn this into a pirate base
a Pirate Bay
too bad you're asking you don't make me
look like an idiot I really thought
Navarro was gonna make it
they haven't returned a dispatch in
weeks they're swamped they'll never get
an answer in time it can't be
from Rebels I can't ignore me face to
face I love your attitude I think it is
you are right Michael it is Zeb Steve
Blum and everything
you're gonna need it oh he looks great
it's tying in no no no do not put any
more stuff no [__] Tim Meadows
you never once paid for Droids
early in John that was great
you once offered that I might reach out
to you I'm gonna play this whole thing
again I get the gist
it does sound concerning
oh no have you ever heard of Navarro
I have
some time there in fact
I'm not a member Planet oh it's not good
Navarro has reported accounts of Storm
Troopers in the streets and Tie fighters
openly flying above pirate king is
attempting the same thing these events
can all be connected these are
serialized because I'm hearing moth
Gideon never made it to trial
perhaps the leaders of Navarro need to
understand why becoming a republic
signatory is valuable by letting them
suffer
she is great you and your sword didn't
see the light you were captured no
I was liberated
[Music]
all these events it's not coincidence
and by the time it becomes big enough
for you to act it'll be too late
this guy's like the head writer of the
room
I need to lay this out for the audience
the show is about something guys
wow
this escalated quickly
there's a concerning lack of survivors
ah
visiting the mandalorians he knows where
they're located that's what I'm confused
about unless he has a uh tracker or
something
Oh Captain Carson Tava how did you
manage to find us someone I served with
in the Rebellion is amongst your ranks
uh-oh awkward
thanks R5
[Music]
they're about to blow Navarro to Hell
the new Republic has to know that the
Empire is growing again and you think
the pirate king has something to do with
it
interesting but something doesn't smell
right look
it's not your fight I just came to tell
you your friend is in danger then a
Monster eats him
and that's the whole episode just
getting it back so what are you thinking
he's right
I gotta help the guy
yeah
the enemy that decimated this very
covert were Imperials not grief cargas
bounty hunters it's true grief karga is
now a high magistrate and has offered me
attractive land
Perhaps it is time for us to live in the
light once again
on a planet where we are welcome on a
commune and our children can feel what
it is to play in the sunlight with their
helmets on and roasting their heads
farmallorians
I have the speaking Hammer now I fought
against grief cargo I saw many Die to
Save the life of this one tiny foundling
oh he feels bad and now we are asked to
sacrifice yet again
yeah the question we should be asking
ourselves is why why should we lay our
lives down yet again
he told he he's he's he kind of he said
it you gotta listen because we are
mandalorians he risked his life to save
my son did not give up on my child's
life even when even when the rest of us
did the speech took a turn dang this is
the way
this is the word this is the way
they're just getting along this is great
we are Zion if everyone acts as they
should we can use the element of
surprise and defeat an enemy that
outnumbers us nice shot
okay this is gonna be amazing Navarro is
an independent planet and no longer
under Remnant Imperial or New Republic
protection rise of the mandalorians you
lived there once hiding in the sewers
but now
you can be heroes just for one day
ninety percent of them die
you can be martyrs that's okay they
repopulate it really fast they do
oh poor Droid
this feels like Pirates of the Caribbean
in Disneyland yeah yeah I was thinking
this is Disneyland gotta be someone
chasing somebody with a rolling pin yeah
that's exactly it
it's literally exactly that
[Music]
oh
Captain there's a Starfighter
[Music]
imagine
so the same race as the quail character
they did work for the Empire
historically speaking all of you to
return Why is drugu there
and they got you outnumbered ten to one
I like those odds
[Music]
that's a cool looking ship though yeah
right
[Music]
of course here's on me the coast is
clear love the Hammerhead design to it
and the approaching drop point and the
daunting looking paint job prepare to
drop
I've been waiting for this trailer
moment yes
baby baby
go
nice
boom
look I have like a scimitar area clear
team two you with us I want this video
game and I want it now dude open world
Mando video game
[Music]
you're starting to run
do a barrel roll ah baby camera class
fighter transport
love this Power Rangers villain
we won't get away this time
the star bite is a decoy there's a
secondary attack
looks like you'll get away this time
[Music]
come on
thanks salacious krem's cousin
oh great shot wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god oh
nice Get Wrecked
full on Arnold or T2 right there yeah
minigun son
oh God that gotta hurt
damn that one gun
love this pirate Squadron this is dope
pirates of the outer rim
[Music]
love you
he's below you
he's everywhere
damn
[Music]
oh
my god wow all clear Advanced dude
foreign
this is everything I've ever dreamed of
[Music]
awesome damn
it's time to part ways
we're down to our last engine
we have to retreat
[Music]
Focus fire on their last engine
and send the ship crashing into town oh
man
I'll make for a Cool Base wow
POV
epic downfall wow
Now That's What I Call television
all right
little Babu mandalorians I know that we
have been on opposite sides in the past
that is behind us cool hereby seed all
Land from the Western lava Flats to pull
a canyon to the Fine people of Mandalore
amazing you do now have a home welcome
Tesla just shoots him
[Applause]
the armor
oh my God
it's the armor gonna seduce her
remove your helmet
what she
sure
remove your helmet
you've broken the Creed
leave our people have strayed from the
way we must walk the way together oh
mandalorians what are you getting at
here
the old night owls I understand bringing
them on board I was taught
the mrsor existed only in Legends
oh it is a sign that the next age is
upon us
Mandalore must all come together
right now under
walked Both Worlds you were the one who
can unite us
[Music]
oh [__] she gonna make
uh Beau challenged in for the dark saber
that feels like a thing that would need
to happen Boca Don Crees is going off to
bring other mandalorians in Exile to us
but she shows her face yes she does the
town walks Both Worlds she can bring all
tribes together
good Kitty sack off is just too cool
looking to not have her face peace in it
is time to retake Mandalore
thank you
that's awesome damn
[Music]
don't don't mark my guy
that is an imperial shuttle
[Music]
nope almost left a one
oh no
that's some Ridley Scott [__] here yeah
let's do a little dead space right now
let's go any reports in the area
a record of a missing craft in the
region
the details are classified
oh boy R7 launch probe
what is suspenseful
ah cool Pro
that's what she said
I'm sending her transponder signal
oh my goodness no no I don't like it
it's a new Republic prison transport
I'll be damned flight times match the
ship transporting moth Gideon what do
you know they don't appear to be any
survivors
something must remain and moth Gideon's
body is missing there appears to be
something embedded in the cabin wall
getting close on that
[Music]
um
the fragment of best car alloy
taken by
mandalorians oh [__] what
[Music]
whoa who else do we know out there with
some best guard to spare well
the mandalorians who were not with Bo
Katan anymore
sure could be them they're also
historically speaking uh the Imperial
super Commandos were expandalorians
I don't think it's gonna go that path
what was that I don't think it's going
to go that way you know a Boy Can Dream
a Boy Can Dream all right let's chit
chat about a gang you are right Michael
it is Zeb my man Steve Blum and
everything uh what in extraordinary live
action appearance of one of my favorite
animated Star Wars characters that's
crazy yeah uh I mean I was the timeline
made a sense what does that imply though
because he's not with the other rest of
the game I mean well Sabine left off
yeah well
I know he'll be is he is he confirmed to
be innatoka no no so last we left off in
the epilogue of rebels Phoenix Squadron
had gone their separate ways uh Zeb uh
his Homeworld was destroyed by The
Imperials and one of the big arcs uh was
them finding a new uh hyperspace Lane uh
that led to a new plan it where they
were able to bring this all so Vaguely
Familiar I know it's similar correct I
know it's in there uh but it is I know
yeah I binged like so quick admittedly I
watched Rebels like four or five times
just give you an idea of my memory just
to give everyone a Breaking Bad I praise
is my favorite show of all time yeah I'm
watching it for the third time with my
wife because she's never seen it and
ninety percent of the time I'm like I
don't remember any of this that's my
favorite show
like a lot to cook
they jam-packed a lot that's what my
main thing is
yeah but you know last we saw him uh he
was taking a former ISB officer uh and
showing him the home world and the ISB
officer was the one that flipped uh was
the double agent it was just one of my
favorite Arts uh in in Rebels but no I
mean it makes sense that that uh Zed
would be part of the new Republic uh and
I just I thought the live action was
just really really well done I always
was worried about how a lasat would
translate on a live action screen and uh
very pricey CG effect yeah that's
probably the number one reason we won't
see Zeb in Ahsoka uh but he weirdly
looked taller than I remember him in the
show I mean it I know he's taller than
everyone else but he looked even taller
then I was like you remember uh Fallen
order
um the Jedi Master uh of Cal yes yeah
same same species so it's cool we've now
officially seen lasates it's just the
first live action yeah action animation
uh and in a video game so I'm sure I'm
sure everyone else is caught that it is
Zeb right away too but like I just
thought it was one of the creatures well
it was for a minute I was like is it
just a lassade and then once you hear
the the voice I mean uh Steve Blum just
an amazing voice actor all over the
place
um it was just I don't know moments like
that uh where you know for for those of
us that watched Rebels uh it's just a
really nice payoff and a little homage
um
this is a blast and a half in this
episode had a like a substantial amount
of I feel like most of the things that
are fun that you want but also most of
the things that by episode five of eight
you should feel like there's a direction
kind of tying all of them together
um so yeah I thought this was it's been
an interesting season overall I'm
curious to see how they they stick The
Landing but I appreciated the immediacy
of this as well as just the sort of
strange and uncomfortable tones that
peppered the sort of ending of both the
situation with the mandalorians
intervening on the Pirates and Boca tan
and the armor are having this whole sort
of you know maybe you should take up the
torch exchange and then you're trying to
lift the camera trying to force choke me
into we have an audio version on our
like Spotify and stuff but you guys
can't see what I'm doing yeah yeah yeah
my goal is just to throw John off his
face
and you have everyone on the audio side
have no idea what's happening why John's
trailing uh but yeah so many uh
disparate threads from both across this
season as well as across just the whole
show kind of coming into the light and
yeah you have your sort of micro
situation with grief karga the
mandalorians finding hope for the future
I thought was really kind of just a nice
cathartic thing and I like the way that
they really kind of wound you up and
then gave a nice subversion with Paz
visla actually being like no we should
absolutely take this cause up I thought
that was really kind of rewarding after
you know kind of exactly what you expect
to happen having happened before uh in
just him being you know sort of
naturally in opposition
um that's true it's an interesting Tim
Meadows appearance
which it worked perfect
it was the perfect character for that
exact kind of role he's the red yeah I'm
very fascinated because I've heard at
least some some vague criticisms of the
show at this point being sort of like
okay we don't really know what the
perspective is as we're looking out at
the new Republic at the you know
remnants of the Empire even the
Persistence of these mandalorians and
the other you know kind of disparate
groups across the Galaxy other than like
the basics of just like ah we want to
have our society and live in peace and
whatever so I'm curious to see because
it seems like in casting uh Tim Meadows
here as this new Republic officer it
seems like so many of the new Republic
people are a bit dweebie or sad sackish
or just ineffectual seeming and then
you've got this guy like blue who's sort
of caught in the middle of it who's like
that beat cop who just wants to actually
make a difference and getting caught up
such a great way to put it yeah and so
like I'm I'm curious to see that theme
like be
substantially committed to but like I
can feel the sort of like seeds of it
there yeah well I mean you're describing
the birth of the resistance uh which is
something that like when the sequel
films came out I did not jive with I was
like this just seems a little why are
they just kind of thrown in the towel on
the new Republic you know why did Leia
feel the need to create this like
paramilitary organization uh and the
reason is because the new Republic is
absolute garbage uh from from what we've
seen and and so I think we're beginning
to see the uh people historically
speaking after a war they kind of lose
the appetite for fighting and uh I think
people are just kind of content for a
little bit of calm you know when in
reality uh when you're dealing with evil
space fascists uh you gotta always be
vigilant so
yeah no it this was such a great episode
in that
I think Navarro as we all talked about
in the beginning of the Season it was
really wonderful to watch the
transformation of this planet uh and and
now for the mandalorians to really kind
of plant their flag and have a new home
base uh you know the the mandalorians
are much more than just Mandalore as
it's kind of been alluded to you know it
was at one point very much an Empire and
of itself you know with with lots of
different systems and lots of different
planets and uh I kind of love the
implication that maybe this is the
beginning of that uh and you know I
think
they've really subverted expectation
uh particularly between the armorer and
bow which I think all of us really felt
strongly they were not gonna get along
um but I feel like they're you know
little finger and verus kind of using
each other in a in a poetic way to to
achieve a means to an end
um but like
Boca town is a really controversial like
I love her
um but might not be the one to actually
make this happen
um and I'm beginning to think that they
are going to die a heroic death that
will lead to the return of the
mandalorians truly
um but I do not see a world in which
they are actually capable of leading the
mandalorians
um so yeah Greg what did you think
[Laughter]
yeah no I mean I agree with everyone's
sentiments here I I do I do like how
they handled it I there's something
about the scenes though though with the
armor and Boca tan that they I feel like
they purposely play up a little even now
it's like it's there's something leading
in that feels like a dark presence is
looming amongst that like in the
atmosphere between their conversations
uh until she like goes out there to talk
and it sucks about like hey let's accept
the fact that we got kind of different
denominations and it's just about
everyone coming together and it's not
about which which uh religion is the
proper way to go about it you know we're
all Christians guys well I was gonna I
was gonna it does give a lot of those
Crusade type Vibes where it's like all
right Orthodox and Catholics we're just
gonna remember that the Muslims are in
Jerusalem and well what happens though
when you're dealing with very passionate
people though people like Vizsla whoever
Bo Katan decides to bring by is you I I
guess I'm wondering if Star Wars is
gonna chicken out and not actually do
something interesting with different
ideologies and
like like if Isla was a little bit
surprised to see her helmet was off but
is that going to create a ripple effect
of distrust uh their Mantra being so
much of being this is the way with this
being the a specific way to live and
[__] what didn't just had to go
through just to get back in
how can they accept the fact that
there's other man and will the show do
that or are they going to be like no
we're just hopeful and nice and we're
gonna be coming together yeah well I I
think it's it's this idea of conversion
where they're welcome to come into the
fold also bathe in the Living Waters of
the minds of Mandalore and then at that
point be able to walk the way but in
order to get them there you've got to
get them there and I think there is a
surprising amount of wisdom coming from
a cult leader uh in the form of the
armorer uh in in in trying to bring in
the night owls and any other kind of
mandalorians
um you know I just I agree with you the
the tone it always feels so Sinister and
dark uh and it feels like the
mandalorians are just like doomed to
repeat their history over and over and
over again and you know the what kind of
preceded all of this
was you know book 10 sister uh who was
part of like the peace loving
mandalorians who tried to break that
cycle and it worked out so well for them
um and so yeah I I know you're talking
about Duchess Satine yeah Obi-Wan the
pacifist one of the mandalorians and it
created a whole problem for everyone
yeah sure did God got killed I remember
that not Zeb
the only thing that matters well it's uh
I mean Obi-Wan Kenobi is the father of
the confusing nephew of bog Katan and
the uh The Duchess sure uh damn a lot of
the directors were [__] in this
episode I want one episode where only
the director
felony family
in this episode Where's the where's
Dallas hours
that was wild I just noticed that right
now yeah um well yeah I mean but as an
episode as a whole I thought while it
was very entertaining the the pirate
there is something about
when you're translating live like I
don't have the Pirates ever been in
Clone Wars Rebels I don't recall not
those particularly nothing is like Vain
and all that piracy is a concept exists
with these guys
as much as they were like blowing up
Navarro and stuff the show It's the
episode itself
as big and scopic as beautiful as a lot
of these shots were
I like more of the context of where it
all led us to I felt more
um tension and suspense and stakes in
like the last minute of this episode and
the in the dread in the dread space
moment then anything dealing with the
Pirates agreed and that's something that
I feel like this ought to have had it
does and that's why I'm kind of hoping
that okay we're five episodes in yeah
and they tease something that feels off
about these conversations like like one
of them's manipulating the it just seems
that way I don't know if we're reading
into it but they play some dark ass
music and they they talk slow to each
other if it's a Donut's a waste yeah
that's an absolute if it's a fake out it
would be a bit of a drink no yeah
instead of just like yeah we all get
along hooray I think they're building to
something that is going to be a little
Sinister and is it just going to be
something as simple as you know the
Empire is lurking in the shadows again
they're on the rise you got someone in
the new Republic who they think is
reformed or liberated but she's really
helping to you know string things up
yeah yeah we have that going on we got
MAF has been broken out who else might
be siding with the dark side right as
the first order blah blah blah and then
what mandalorians they fight alongside
them and where were they in the sequel
Trilogy do they all die by the end like
is that where we're going with this is
that they all band together because I
like it when it's more intimate and
personal with them and I think that um
that was one thing like this episode was
really fun uh but it did lack a certain
substance of of of emotional weight
rather than just like I like the context
a lot I think that's been a challenge
that they've had since bringing all the
mandalorians together uh it's almost
like these victory feel a little bit too
inevitable
um and because of that the stakes are
never really as high as they should be I
mean that that last you know two minutes
of the episode uh I think a lot of that
tension is because it captures a lot of
the tone of something like Andor
um where it it's a
I I mean that's like like it's one of
the things that I love about the
Mandalorian it's one of the things that
I hate about the Mandalorian is that it
there's this constant desire to emulate
like the Fantastical craziness of of
something like the Clone Wars yeah
um but it doesn't always translate to
live action and and sometimes those
those darker more grounded live-action
moments just feel a lot heavier and and
like the stakes are there yeah this
season is so far felt like it's it's
bigger and way more action like it's
been feeling that way like it's bigger
and way more action yet it hasn't felt
as uh within its action scenes as truly
emotionally gripping is even in the way
of like when the socatanos uh return
episode uh the one that like really felt
like it was riffing on like uh Seven
Samurai in a way even though I don't
know these people and everything there's
a certain mood about it where like this
is captivating and here you're just like
this is big cool yeah you know yeah and
there's a quality too where like during
this episode I did find myself getting
distracted going like okay while you
guys are sitting around while while
you're flying across the Galaxy to get
approval for this backup and while you
mandalorians are arguing about whether
or not to go to Navarro in the first
place these Pirates can decimate
anything that matters kind of
immediately and when they get there you
have this like little pocket of all them
and they kind of get out of town and you
get this like yeah they've destroyed
stuff but you don't feel the true harsh
like they're they're just massacring
innocent people and you don't really
have that flavor actually present in the
episode and so well that's why I was
liking it to the Ahsoka episode sure
because that's the first time you check
in with them
and it just seems like a a such a bleak
miserable situation yeah yeah this still
feels real bright and colorful no I mean
we did I think we described it best I
mean it was like the Pirates of the
Caribbean sequence and like where it's
like weirdly kind of fun like like oh
look at this occupation uh and the
salacious crumbs getting shot I didn't
get a true sense of the suffrage yeah
well and there's also a thing too that
yeah like a true sense of the suffering
and the and just the the sheer harshness
of like this is like you know they don't
adhere to any law but this is like a war
crime of of massive proportions
essentially
um but also I think there is a certain
thing that to me it makes me curious
because I think there's a potential for
the show to be at odds with itself in
the fact that when the show was just
about din jarin I feel like you can have
your Mandalorian cake a little bit and
eat it too in the sense that you have
all the Mystique but you don't
necessarily have to confront it as
head-on as you do when you have them all
together and trying to like reform their
whole uh culture and Society because the
Mandalorian culture is one rot on like
violence and all sorts of conquest and
things that are like really dark and
hard to rectify in a way that's like a
really easy to root for protagonist
situation ideal for Disney plus yeah so
I feel like even though it is like fun
and interesting to watch them rebuild at
the same time I'm like how much is this
show gonna have to kneecap itself from
the true potential of what's really
interesting about that without nerfing
the mandalorians or like creating this
weird face turn that doesn't quite jive
with the rest of the Galaxy I'm gonna
make a weird comparison here uh I feel
like The Walking Dead had the same exact
issue uh in the early Seasons it was
really intimate and personal and then it
it wanted to evolve into a very
different type of show where all of a
sudden there's like settlements and
factions and it's much bigger and it
never really knew how to make that
transition and I feel like this season I
hope is The Growing Pains of them
figuring that out and that they do
figure it out by next season because the
stakes are much higher than just DIN and
grogu uh and and I think that you know
kudos to them for being brave enough to
try uh and I I think
I'm gonna have nothing but but faith in
optimism uh in our Lord and savior
that's all no I still quite like I I
just think the first and this episode
were the ones that I I don't I like this
more than the first episode yeah
um I do it's just more like yeah this is
this was fun with a a very interesting
last few minutes yeah
with the armor and stuff um but yeah
there is a lack of tension yeah the most
tense when there should be tension in a
lot of even the scene when you had
um oh my God wait a minute I have the
castles right here what is his name
what's what's the Asian guys do oh he
kept saying it blue blue for sure
there's something with a c yeah it's uh
uh boy Crimson Chris Pine for something
well anyway with that seem a blue and
Carson Carson Carson you're right about
that yeah Carson uh Carson and Tim
Meadows and the girl from the episode
that was divisive for people that I I
love I second that I love that was the
most tense and most sort of intimately
perilous feeling I love that episode
yeah that one
um but yeah I thought that um that scene
too was like ah this is kind of like
moving it's like the first episode let's
move a little quick let's move a little
too quick for me yeah it's those
multiple povs and it's that transition
to that type of show that is just uh I
cannot imagine how that writer's room
like their formula you just had to throw
out but I think the second and third
episode were [__] fantastic I think
the second third episode were really
fantastic they weren't afraid to be
intimate and the focused was this the
fourth fifth fifth what was the fourth
episode
[__] what happened last week finding out
who's safe grow goo oh yeah oh yeah
it was just a pure blast but yeah yeah
I'm getting back from yeah I think
that's the challenge really quick
episode yeah I know absolutely a lot in
it yeah this is an interestingly shaped
and and tonally paced you think it would
be more focused and breathe better
considering how serialized it is I feel
like there was a shortage of Adderall in
the writer's room this season yeah it
was a little Ryan Murphy yeah but but
you know what it's still so fun true and
uh you know that's what Star Wars is at
its core uh fun to the point where
you're angry about it
because you're not having the right kind
of fun that I'm having final final
thoughts please final five it's been 23
minutes yeah I was this was a good talk
uh the best scar Alloy at the end uh I I
feel like you might be onto something
with it being the the night owls and and
those kind of abandoned bow but part of
me also wonders like this guy occupied
Mandalore and had access to like bescar
I wonder if there is some cool stuff
that we haven't seen yet
um true so you know and for the rebels
fans thrown out my last little nerdy
tidbit here but like I also wouldn't be
surprised if you know the the Gara
saxon's relatives uh who was the
Imperial Mandalorian uh there were
Imperial mandalorians and I don't want
to write that off because I feel like as
you talked about the different sects uh
of the Mandalorian culture
that would be really neat to show that
that was you know part of what played a
role in the downfall of Mandalore so
final ticks shows cone a bit mcu-ish
come on
yeah Spaceballs in the beginning no
anyway guys thanks for being here uh
what did you think about the episode
though please leave your thoughts down
below I'll respond uh follow Michael
check us on patreon get that data shirt
also listen to the patreon
Everett pixelmite Baker my dude listen
up there are so many people that would
be the the de facto you know person that
we would Heap the mantle of the reject
Nation on who walk both worlds and you I
think are the most uh you know resilient
person to do that for us because you
here walk two identities you have
Everett Baker mild-mannered citizen of
the world you know just out here
supporting their favorite channels but
within you have pixel might who's who
knows the potential of what you could do
with power based in pixels of the
foundations of the modern world man we
do everything on pixelated displays
every image you see is an amalgamation
of smaller bits and pieces and that is
the power the strength that exists
within you so let it free
and thus he maintain your pledge to the
patreon because that's like the Living
Water that's how you keep your you know
Creed status in good standing and good
faith with us but other than that you
know don't be an apostate don't be an
apostate and Chuck your prostate because
uh physical health is also a good thing
you know can confirm love you Everett
stay well and we'll catch you for an
even better more coherent shout out next
month love you buddy see you buddy